so JD goes on a tenday what is a
honeymoon first anniversary kind of trip
and I could tell he was miserable oh
dude
his wife is out there jet skiing while
JD stays in the hotel what yeah
[Music]
dude what are you doing man why bother
you in the hotel room maybe she told JD
to stay home dude no hi JD you stay in
the room I'll be back in it in about a
week like that then it's not that much
of a relationship in the first place I'm
the trip JD went to a casino okay the
beach vineyards and even did an 11 mile
hike oh he didn't want to do that oh
wait wait wait he hurt his hands he's
got a shoe they visited Napa Yosemite
and Lake Tahoe allness this trip okay
the best pictures that I saw was JD's
trip began with the stay at the new TWA
hotel that's part of JFK Airport oh it's
your you're in a hotel at the airport
Airport in New York it takes a little
bit to get to JFK well my dear early I
was going nuts and then JD's wife
apparently goes swimming and JD doesn't
well he can't swim yeah but I mean why
don't you swim remember that time we
sent him to that place and he almost
drowned yeah and three feet of water at
hedonism but you do get in a bathing
suit
I didn't so your wife goes out to the
pool what do you do while she's at the
pool by the pool but you said you didn't
go to the pump I hung like in your
clothes yeah you're wait a second you
hang out a pool and vacation and your
clothes I mean this was one day but yeah
hey Gary Howard this is everybody Gary
Dell'Abate sometimes known as ba-ba-boom
five here's a picture of JD on the beach
fully clothed let me see this JD oh my
god gotta be hot look at him could you
wear more and what's your wife were in a
bathing suit right yeah are
wearing flip-flops or do you wear
knickers raincoat and a raincoat rankle
okay so water splashes I actually
prepare a JD puppet how are you mister
alright thank you very much and then JD
took an uncomfortable plane ride out to
California because he had the middle
seat were you like [ __ ] this vacation
already just being on the plane for
frying
[Music]
and JD lands in Napa Valley they visited
four wineries and then JD went to places
that featured Pinot Noir did you know
this he told us he likes peanut yeah
because that's the type of wine he like
yeah listen to this JD bought a hundred
dollar bottle of wine in Napa 100 I
don't know why but he did and described
it as so freakin good you've come a long
way from collecting spoons and jizz
shirts
oh good you have a wine cellar now we
have like a little cabinet that we put
like a couple lines and JD and his wife
also took a wine train in Napa the Wine
Train there's this little train it was
an all-day trip they visited three
wineries in between each winery they
were served food on the train right JD
called the courses fancy type plates
what does that mean like just regularly
like train food or whatever it's like a
upscale plate it wasn't on a paper plate
yes but it was fancy Fuji China chicken
fingers on China I was like beef or
salmon yeah and there's like a thing of
bacon in the morning oh well thing a
bacon yeah that bacon thing fancy bacon
thing Mac in fact aren't fancy real
Forks and I'm plastic then they drove
the best part is they drove to Yosemite
Park and they went on a short hike to
see a waterfall and JD fell and hurt his
hands because he hates hiking JD says
they didn't get close to the waterfall
they were trying to see because he was
scared of slipping on the rocks and
dying
the next day JD and his wife went on a
12 mile round trip hike to Glacier Point
in the park what part of this was fun
for you you hate hiking factors that led
to me doing this hike what was the
factor well we had a good parking spot
and I didn't want to move the car and
also there I didn't know where I didn't
want to lose gas because I didn't know
the gas situation there what where do
you go
but don't you eventually have to move
the car when you leave the park yes I
didn't want to waste all that gas
driving to this at
back and forth to this point and didn't
have to leave the part when we leave the
park I don't have enough gas until uh
you know to get to the next spot and
then I hadn't might have stepped in
Buffalo [ __ ] and then I would have been
driving in the car with the Buffalo [ __ ]
on my shoe and it would have stunk up
the whole corner iron ore and what does
this have to do with Goonies somebody
said well I'd seen the movie I haven't
done a lot of theater as things in my
life so the the movie The Goonies had
come on the past couple times I caught
it on TV and that inspired me to be more
adventurous Goonies despite you watch
Goonies more than once
Wow well maybe finally inspired you to
do something yes lady ate chips and ice
cream when he got to the top of the hike
by the way Hank JD pub ah look at that
fist over white chip form good for you
man I'm not busting your balls I'm just
trying to you know say hey well done I'm
saying you're happy I like it yeah I
could listen to you all day
you